إذا أتيت إلى زامبيا اليوم لتأسيس
نشاط تجاري ، فلن يستغرق الأمر أقل من
48 ساعة لإنشاء نشاط تجاري
[موسيقى]
مثيرًا للاهتمام بما يكفي ، حيث كانت إحدى أهم
النقاط التي تم الحصول عليها من معرض إكسبو 2020
هذه المرة هي رؤيتها  كيف
يمكننا الاستفادة بشكل أفضل من منطقة الخليج
فيما يتعلق
بالنفط والغاز
فيما يتعلق بالزراعة فيما
يتعلق بالتعدين
بشكل واضح والسياحة ولكن ماذا لو
نظرت إلى الأشياء الثلاثة
القطاعات الثلاثة التي التقطتها التعدين
والزراعة والسياحة هذا هو  ما
نريد الاستفادة منه في منطقة الخليج ، نريد
أن يصل العديد من الأشخاص من الإمارات العربية المتحدة
في منطقة الخليج إلى دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي للوصول إلى
فرص زامبيا للحصول على
فرص ترفيهية للأعمال التجارية ، نتحدث
عن قدومهم لإقامة معسكرات فاخرة
داخل منطقتنا  المتنزهات الوطنية
[الموسيقى]
فيما يتعلق بالنفط والغاز ، فأنت
تدرك أنك تجلس
على الذهب السائل ويحبون تسميته
، وبصراحة تامة في الوقت الحالي في
زامبيا ، نعتمد كثيرًا من الوقود
على دفع عجلة الاقتصاد  نحن نحاول
معرفة أفضل السبل التي يمكننا من خلالها الوصول إلى
نفط أرخص من منطقة الخليج لا يزال
رئيس دولتي في
جميع أنحاء البلاد ويجري
مناقشات مع مجتمع الأعمال
في دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي لمعرفة أفضل السبل التي
يمكننا الاستفادة منها  في الغالب
والأهم هو الزراعة التي
نود إطعام منطقة الخليج
التي نرغب في إطعامها ، فنحن نجلس على 40
مليون هكتار من الأراضي الصالحة للزراعة
حاليًا في زامبيا
[موسيقى]
زامبيا بلد متصل بالأرض
نحن فيه  من الواضح أن المركز
في إفريقيا جنوب الصحراء الكبرى ونحن على
اتصال بمختلف البلدان مما
يمنحنا فرصة كبيرة جدًا
، والشيء الثاني هو ثقافتنا
لدينا ثقافة فريدة جدًا في زامبيا ،
فالناس دافئون ولدينا 72 قبيلة و
إنه لأمر مدهش كيف يمكنك فعلاً
إدارة 72 شخصًا
معًا تلك الرائحة الدافئة طوال
الوقت تقريبًا ومن الواضح أن الثالثة هي
بيئة العمل
لدينا فريدًا جدًا لدينا
بيئة عمل مرحب بها للغاية
ronment ويمكننا أن نضمن لك أنه مهما كان
الاستثمار
الذي تستثمره في زامبيا ،
فإنك تحصل على عائد
استثماري مضمون وهذا ما يجعلنا
مختلفين عن البلدان الأخرى التي
لدينا عبر
جيراننا ، لذلك من حيث بيئة الأعمال ،
ما شجعناه بالفعل
الكثير من المستثمرين
وللتيسير عليهم هو الشراكة مع
السكان
المحليين بالطريقة الوحيدة التي ستحققها جيدًا بالفعل ،
ربما أريد أن أقول إن لديك
ممرًا آمنًا حتى لا أقول إنه
قيد أو أي نوع من أي نوع ولكن  هو أن تكون
شريكًا محليًا الآن ، هناك
سببان لسبب اعتقادنا أنه يجب علينا
الشراكة مع محلي هو رقم واحد ،
يجب أن تكون قادرًا على معرفة الطرق القليلة التي يجب أن
تسلكها ،
وهذا
رقم واحد هو الحوافز التي يتمتع
بها السكان المحليون أفضل من
الأجنبي.  يحدث في جميع أنحاء العالم تمييز إيجابي ،
لذلك نود أن نشجع
الآن
من حيث الاضطرار إلى الاستثمار ، لقد قدمنا
ًا حوافز خا
ة في ميزانية 2022 وا
مضي قدمًا  نحن نتحدث عن
الفرص المتاحة للمستثمرين للدخول
ومن ثم تحصل على
إعفاءات ضريبية
عند تقديم الطلب الآن الطريقة الوحيدة التي
ستحصل بها على هذا الخصم الضريبي أو بالأحرى
تنازل هي عندما تتقدم بطلب للحصول على
تصريح استثمار تحت جناح الاستثمار لدينا
والتي تسمى
وكالة التنمية في زامبيا ، لذا فهي تمنحك
تصريح استثمار لمدة 10 سنوات في تلك السنوات العشر ،
يتم تحفيز كل النفقات الرأسمالية بالفعل
لأنك حصلت على الخصومات
الخاصة بك ، وقد حصلت على إعفاءات على واردات
ما تريد  اتصل بالسلع
الرأسمالية وستجدها مثل
ونحن ننشئ صفحة مقصودة آمنة
لك